so someone who
neither of us mentioned who
we just talked about ran like real quick
who i think a lot of uh
younger people would would take offense
to us not saying his name
for whatever reason um i don't got him
on my list you don't got him
but nba young boy yeah um
i don't think he's like the best like
when i think of the best rapper i don't
think nba young boy comes to mind
i listen to his album um i think he
dropped like four projects this year
something some
some insane amount i listen to the last
one and um
and he's doing the numbers you don't i
don't care about the numbers you know
what i'm saying i mean
i think that tells a story i don't think
it tells the whole story
uh he he's super popular like you said
on youtube and
but i just don't i wasn't blown away by
anything that he said there wasn't
nothing that was like
guys let me press the rewind button i
didn't get that from
yeah i enjoy some of his [ __ ] because
obviously like i'm a club dj so there's
certain [ __ ] they're like i'm like yo
this [ __ ] goes up but like as far as
like
this year i haven't heard some nba young
boy [ __ ] that like was like
damn that [ __ ] was hard like it's just
maybe it's just not for me some
look some of this [ __ ] i've realized by
the way
i still haven't listened to uzi's album
so
i let my son tell me about it i'm just
like yo i already you know i
i just i've kind of just maybe that [ __ ]
that's that on my behalf like i probably
should tap in with i've heard a lot of
it you know that i've like
that that i've listened to but i haven't
like sat down
and pressed play and just let it ride
yeah i know i kind of know what you're
getting into when you listen to the uzi
album like
it's like the thing it was a correct
well
but i don't think he showcases it that
much on his albums on the the future
project that he did he had that song
called
about like he really went in like okay
give me more of this uzi
but um he's more like vibes and things
like that but i wouldn't
put uzi on my best rapper list i
couldn't do that
real quick um it's crazy because
the the most memorable verses that i can
think of this year when i say verses i
don't mean the battle but like people's
verses
um they they're they're free
like to me that the one that now mind
you i really have to sit down and think
about this
but i think of conway
firing the booth that's you know what
you asked me about a moment that's what
i wanted to say
conway's freestyle on charlie slaw
wow bruh i watch that once a week
i do too you know also i also watched
your joint with freddie gibbs when you
did last year
oh yeah you know what you know funny
story about that is fred came to the
studio and was like uh
like we're doing an interview and then i
was like oh you know you got a rap right
and he literally wrote that [ __ ] in like
five minutes
and then nailed it yeah like he was like
yo uh pick a beat so we picked the drake
money in the grave and then
he was like just let me chill in here
for five minutes and just come up with
something
and then he was like come back in and
then he laid it down
no [ __ ] yeah wow he didn't come to the
station that day with the
expectations to rap and then he laid
down some crazy [ __ ] that's
amazing fred's a [ __ ] mutant like
that's i thought that was like prepared
no nah bro yeah no fred's a [ __ ]
alien bro
and then obviously you know he did the
l.a leakers freestyle last year which
was [ __ ] crazy yes baby
yeah once a week bro be an actual
remix with him and uh dom kennedy
another verse that like
it it also is la leakers verse this year
um
and that's the simba freestyle man yo
get out of my head kev
yo i was just about to say kev simba
is going to be a problem like if i had
to do an honorable mention
best rap he's on that list he's
whoo simba is amazing
that freestyle yo was [ __ ]
crazy simba is nice so many and just the
confidence and the
and just the delivery of those lines and
that freestyle we're so
s like and mind you out he's a really
good friend of mine like
really good close like he was on our
show like three years ago like to give
you some insight i've been known simba
for a while
and man his project is you know it's
crazy because his project
didn't come out the way it was supposed
to come out so like two weeks ago they
were playing me some like they
a lot of the songs were on there right
but like there's there's a song called
west side griselda that was supposed to
be on the album
with him and jason cash that because the
samples didn't work out but
but yes simba's crazy he's he's
incredible like i'm interested to see
what he's going to do in 2021
like he's the kind of rap i like rappers
like that it's like when you when i
listen to them it makes me want to quit
rapping
and i can't even rap right like what am
i doing this for
it's like [ __ ] let me start from scratch
like
he's he's a rapper's rap he's dope man
like i want to get
more in tune to what he's got going on
in 2021
yeah i think he's gonna have a crazy
year um and then and then i think the
congrats russ freestyle was probably
uh up there as well i think and it's
crazy because those are the three that
just come to my head and
and i'm not saying that there aren't
better verses but it's like all three of
those verses are all from freestyles
technically
absolutely the congratulation from russ
is really dope um i listen to that
probably like once a week as well
um love the absolute verse on you didn't
put absolutes verse on your on your
features i wanted to pick one from each
other that's fair i'm going to put
multiple but it could have
easily went absolutely i went with the
crooked eye because he set the tone
and yes crooked i just went ape [ __ ] on
that
that uh on stockholm syndrome um but
i like freddie gibbs man freddy gibbs on
100 ounce 500 ounces
on west side guns album was that was the
one where you had the line about uh
about uh take a load off this low
management right yeah
yeah yeah that [ __ ] was crazy like marcy
and west side
i love that b alchemist is a [ __ ]
fool
uh he killed that joint i love
conway conway whatever kind conway and
freddie are like ken and ryu like i'm on
the edge of my seat anytime he's right
yeah conway is is my um he's my favorite
um like when it comes to just like his
his versatility to be able to like just
kill you with some crazy bars
or just give you like the most relatable
verse about some crazy traumatic [ __ ]
he's
like man i know he's not like the you
know the most like yo benny's the guy
right now right
but i think conway is like like he's
like the people's champ
if that makes sense he's right there man
he played me a record con
i'm telling you now on your show kev
he's sitting
on a hit he played me um
his entire shady album so i might have
heard it
um maybe how long would he play for you
couple weeks ago okay okay he might be
something new yeah because he was up
here
in probably october september and he
played me like
this was before his album dropped so it
was like a a couple weeks prior
but then he played me his whole [ __ ]
the whole shady records debut
yeah that's the same one i heard he has
a record i said it on live so it's not a
secret or anything like that he has a
record produced by hitmaker
and um produ produced by hitmaker
oh you know he played me some other [ __ ]
that was um i want to say
jeremiah was on the hook or something
and he was like i heard that he was like
i don't think
i don't think we can get this one
cleared though yeah yeah i heard that's
a monster but this is what i'm talking
about
i didn't hear the stuff on dawn record
but yo it's crazy because we did talk
about a lot of the records like you know
because we did like an hour-long
interview and i was just talking about
both albums he had just played me
neither was out so he's got some big
features and you know i'm excited for
him man shout out to conway i think
griselda is going to have even i mean
benny's got two records with drake
tucked
like i heard those but i like you know
what it is about this [ __ ] too
i love what benny the [ __ ] zelda
movement
russ and freddie have been doing this
year it's like they're
stockpiling this ammunition a lot of
these rappers took a break this year man
but these guys have been consistently
working
and i feel like 2021 once we get through
this pandemic is going gonna be a
big breakout year for those guys because
of the music that they have been putting
out
do you think also like the in this what
i told um
fred and benny i was like you know
what's dope about 2020 obviously it
sucks you can't hit the road but
you know people are listening to music
differently they're listening to someone
in their headphones
they're listening to it in their car
because they're driving uber all day
they're not standing on couches
you know what i mean and so i feel like
this year
was a special moment to like really like
say something in your music absolutely
absolutely i feel like you know people
feel like rap music only exists in the
nightclub or in the lounge
places where i like to i'm not listening
to the turn i'm doing when i'm cleaning
my house or i'm in my car
i just wanted to listen to some really
good rap music with meaningful lyrics so
just something entertaining
and those guys have been doing that
throughout this whole year
so you know like you said people are
listening a little bit differently you
know i'm not mad at that like let's
let's get back to the lyrics you know
and um we can still have fun we can
still
sing throw baby but shout out to throw
baby